and let's bring you some breaking news  now or concerning chelsea football club  uh the takeover has been completed uh  the new owner is todd bowley uh his  consortium have this afternoon  officially taken over from roman  abramovich at chelsea um roman  abramovich's era is now over this is a  4.25  billion takeover led by todd bowley who  is an american uh businessman uh the  west london club of course put up for  sale in march over roman abramovich was  sanctioned by the uk government over his  links to the russian president vladimir  putin following the invasion of ukraine  earlier  this year and chelsea have been  operating of course since then um but  todd bowley and the clear lake capital  investment group have just completed  the takeover